so I've been flooded I mean truly
flooded with emails from viewers about
what is going on with YouTube lately and
this has gotten so big that it is beyond
the David Pakman show at this point in
time my recent coverage of what's going
on with YouTube has actually been quoted
and cited in a bunch of different
articles about what is taking place and
I am actually going to show you a few of
the emails I've gotten from viewers
which have confirmed to me that what's
going on is even worse than I thought
and I thought it was pretty bad now if
you miss the story on Monday the big
picture is that YouTube has changed
their algorithm over time but acutely
since the first day of May of this year
to drastically reduce the number of
recommendations that it makes for
viewers of YouTube to look at
independent news and politics channels
like this one or like sam cedars or like
kyle colon skis and has instead shifted
those recommendations to legacy
corporate youtube channel so CNN has a
youtube channel foxnews has a YouTube
channel MSNBC likewise has a YouTube
channel also shifting views from
independent channels like ours to the
YouTube channels for these big
late-night talk shows produced by mega
corporations with thousands and
thousands of employees or even tens of
thousands of some of these huge mega
corporations I now have for you today an
absolutely devastating image that sums
this up in total okay so on Monday I
gave you some of the micro examples that
are powerful but they are anecdotal okay
so example number one I showed you the
recommendation numbers over time which
show that at the same time that
recommended views to my channel and to
sam cedars and Kyle Cole in skis and
right-wingers Steven Crowder's Channel
when those recommendations went down the
recommendations to CNN and Fox News and
MSNBC went up but of course there are
way more channels than just our four
channels and those three corporate media
channels and even if I can find a bunch
of these micro correlations we really
need more if we're going to make a
broader claim about what's going on with
YouTube and I now have it for you and it
is devastating Marc led which compiled
all of this data and built a tool to
lies it and he sent this to me this is
not a channel by channel analysis this
is the aggregate of hundreds of the
major news and politics channels on
YouTube ok this analysis includes all
YouTube channels with ten thousand or
more subscribers that have 30 percent or
more of their content as US politics or
US cultural news and commentary what you
saw in the early part of the year is
that there was a sort of balance around
40 to 50 percent of YouTube's news and
politics recommendations were two
independent channels like mine and about
40 to 50 percent of YouTube's news and
politics recommendations were for what
we call TV cable legacy media that have
YouTube channels this includes CNN and
Fox News and MSNBC and then you see that
at the end of March and more acutely
even at the end of April beginning of
May that even 50/50 split imploded and
lately 75 percent and climbing of
YouTube's recommended news and politics
views are legacy corporate TV cable
channels while only about twenty four
and a half percent and dropping of the
recommendations are left for all of the
independent channels to split amongst
ourselves so it's really important to
understand there are way fewer big
corporate cable TV YouTube channels so
when the few YouTube I'm sorry when the
few corporate cable TV channels are
splitting 75% of the recommendations and
a ton of independent channels are
splitting 25% of the recommendations the
degree of inequality is stunning and
this is the opposite of what YouTube
used to be this is terrible this data is
devastating and in the meantime the
individual video D monetization z' are
exploding this image we're putting up on
the screen is from yesterday three of
our first four videos were demonetized
as you can see by the yellow dollar sign
rather than the green dollar sign we
spent all day researching and producing
those three of them earn zero despite
getting lots of views some over a
hundred thousand views in the first 12
hours the Trump child rape 1 I
understand
and the others not so much now for
people who write in and say David don't
you have a youtube representative who
can help you with what's going on I do
she's been telling me for three weeks
that she's quote waiting for more
information
historically that means that after a
month or two I'll get some kind of form
letter that communicates nothing of
value check out some of these emails
from the audience Nicole says hello just
want to say I'm not getting
recommendations for your videos from
YouTube any more when I subscribed last
year I would get recommendations every
day down to zero now not a problem
because I'm a member and I'm watching
the full show every day still don't
understand why YouTube doesn't mention
you anymore your show is one of my
favorites worth every penny Phillipe
says for the past few weeks I noticed
that there are fewer and fewer of your
daily videos showing up whenever I type
David Pakman in the search bar of
YouTube it shows lots of older videos
though but just two or three new videos
now just thought I'd point out my
experience if it can help you grit says
I am frequently watching the following
shows David Pakman ring of fire secular
talk and it looks like the algorithm is
specifically after your show I have
subscribed to your show on YouTube and
receive emails when you upload new
videos even so when I open a new iniya
window in YouTube the recommendation
line never includes your show despite my
frequent visit to your YouTube page and
watching it Samantha says I'm constantly
unsubscribed from your channel on
YouTube
I've been subscribed for years notice
your videos are gone go to your channel
page and the subscribe button is not
pressed I click it and subscribe for a
few days then the same thing again
YouTube unsubscribes me from your
channel
Simon Says I've been a member in one way
or another for years I'm also a YouTube
premium subscriber and I listen to this
show and other progressive shows well
like commute or work at my office lately
I've had to constantly reopen the
YouTube app and find and click on your
videos after having just watched one
MSNBC has been popping up as the up next
video way more often than normal and
it's gotten really annoying
and lastly Michael says David after
watching your video I have to admit my
recommendation feed has been bothering
me a subscriber I don't see you Kyle or
Sam cedar the last two weeks have been
particularly poor
some folks have written in and said
David what about just going to another
platform I'm invited to three
alternative platforms every week the
problem is they have no traffic they
have no funding they have terrible
design and they have no monetization so
there's no actual advantage to switching
over to a platform that earns no money
and has no audience so here's the bottom
line
okay I think this is how we have to
think about shows at this point in time
I am a service worker we all are at the
show and who are at other shows that you
might watch or like we aren't producing
a physical product we're producing
something in the service space it's like
someone who works as a bartender or
cleaning houses or whatever sometimes
those jobs are paid with a salary
sometimes they're paid hourly sometimes
in the United States there's the
expectation of tips which are of course
optional and we can evaluate whether a
tip makes sense so waitstaff at
restaurants for example they often make
263 an hour that's their hourly wage so
when I go out to eat I tip 20 percent
whenever I go out to eat I don't have to
I value their work and I think their
wage is too low so I choose to pay a 20%
tip in the same way you are under no
obligation to pay directly for shows
that you like we produce this show at
our expense for you we distribute it to
200 public radio and television stations
at our expense because we want to do
that that being said we have no
guaranteed wage from any of our
platforms we give the show to radio and
TV stations we put the show on YouTube
and many of the videos are D monetized
and earn no money there and YouTube's
changes are hurting us if we don't do
well in the tips meaning contributions
from you there is no backup we don't get
any experience Orsini already raised
from the platforms that were on and in
fact the opposite has mostly been
happening over the year now I still give
my employees seniority raises and merit
raises and cost-of-living adjustments I
just eat those costs if you like the job
we are doing for you here think of us as
the wait staff or your bartender but
instead of being guaranteed some minimum
wage we're not so you can choose to
leave a few bucks a month and I don't
care if it's this show or others it's
about supporting the shows you think are
important and valuable there's too
the easy ways to do this get a
membership right on our website it takes
under a minute you get lots of extra
stuff but you were sort of tipping like
you would a waiter or a waitress the
normal prices I think are very
reasonable many of you have signed up in
the last month if you want a discount
but you can use the coupon code this is
20/20 and get 40% off and I'll even go
further and tell you you can use the
coupon code half 19 half 19 and get 50%
off the other is throw us a buck or two
a month on patreon ok that's also easy
you go to patreon.com/scishow click the
orange become a patron button and that's
it you don't have to I understand if you
don't under one percent of the audience
supports us financially we're gonna keep
doing our thing ok but if you find it
valuable then I would appreciate it
let's disconnect our revenue from
advertising as much as possible and to
help us additionally without paying
anything make sure you are subscribed to
the YouTube channel like this video
share this video